et pour en parler nous sommes avec
emmanuel dupuy président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe dont
soir emmanuel dupuis merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
avant le chef de l'état un les chefs
dirait sera ashraf ghani et abdullah
abdullah se déclarent tous les deux
présidents alors déjà comment c'est
possible on a du mal à nous se l'imaginé
depuis la france et bien c'est pas la
première fois que ça arrive des métallos
lors des précédentes élections en 2014
et même en 2009 puisque abdullah
abdullah qui n'a pas la fonction de
premier ministre mais du chef de
l'exécutif puisque la constitution
afghane ne prévoit pas ce poste avait
déjà contesté les élections donc il en
est à sa 3ème contestation il a avalé la
pilule et j'ose dire
lors des deux précédentes de précédentes
élections présidentielles et donc là il
est dans une logique où il ne veut
absolument pas cédé le moindre mètre par
rapport à son adversaire qui qu'il a
péniblement et de manière assez fragile
et exercer le pouvoir
comment est ce possible tout simplement
parce que le processus électoral a été
très compliqué avec un certain nombre de
violences qui ont émaillé ce processus
qui ont empêché d'avoir un certain
nombre de résultats deuxièmement il ya
eu des contestations elles portent sur
l'ensemble des votes avec là aussi il
faut il le rappeler un pourcentage très
faible moins de 10% des neuf millions
d'électeurs se sont déclarés à se sont
présentés au scrutin pour des raisons de
sécurité que j'évoquais précédemment
et donc cette contestation du reste a
toujours lieu puisque le premier
ministre le chef de l'exécutif
adou lab de la part du principe que tous
les votes n'ont pas été recomptées et la
marge de manoeuvre telle qu'elle a été
annoncée
assez rapidement par le président élu
est donc investi aujourd'hui ashraf
ghani ne porte que sur douze mille voix
alors cette crise constitutionnelle
comment on en sort est ce qu elle peut
durer longtemps
il avait fallu trois mois en 2014 et
l'implication personnelle de john kerry
à l'époque secrétaire d'état américain
qui avait fait littéralement la navette
entre les deux camps
quand date de la douleur et le camp
d'achraf années pour obtenir
effectivement ce set
comment dire mariage un petit peu un
petit peu alambiqué entre les deux
hommes qui ne peut plus avoir lieu
puisque les négociations des jours
précédents ils se sont d'ailleurs
déroulée la nuit dernière n'ont pas
abouti on sait avec un certain nombre de
précautions que le président shafran y
est prêt à faire un gouvernement d'union
nationale avec une large part au camp
adverse donc de son adversaire à de la
bouloie 30 à 40% du gouvernement mais
avec une détermination et d'aucune
certitude de ne pas avoir à double
abdullah être de nouveau dans la même
configuration qu'en 2014
comment en sortons tout simplement avec
la pression américaine et je crois
d'ailleurs qu'elle est forte
actuellement le secrétaire d'état
américain p ô a appelé personnellement
achraf rani en lui demandant deux choses
d'accélérer le processus d'investiture
alors qu'il avait reculé les jours
précédents tout simplement parce qu'il y
à une urgence à ce que l'accord qui a
été signé il ya une semaine et dont la
réalisation devrait devait avoir lieu
demain avec la deuxième étape la mise en
place d'un dialogue intra afghans c'est
à dire entre le gouvernement afghan qui
en étaient exclues et la délégation
talibane qui est actuellement à kaboul
et malheureusement ce dialogue va être
tout à fait perturbé d'ailleurs les
talibans ont dit qu'ils étaient prêts à
le repousser
car ils ne veulent surtout pas avoir à
négocier avec un camp sachant que 39 12
% c'est le score de l'actu de l'homme ne
reconnaît pas le résultat de ces
négociations ou ne reconnaîtra pas le
résultat des négociations
alors cette grande confusion
enseignements qu'on puisse dire sur
cette présidentielle alors que l'armée
américaine a commencé à se retirer
d'afghanistan après son accord de paix
signé avec
les talibans ça fait beaucoup ça fait un
départ des américains alors que
finalement l'afghanistan n'est pas du
tout stable cet accord avec les talibans
se demande son efficacité les américains
avaient déjà commencé à se replier bien
avant l'accord l'accord a été repoussée
de plusieurs mois il ya six mois de cela
en sept ans le négociateur zalman
relizane était à deux doigts d'ailleurs
à quelques jours voire quelques heures
de cette signature de cet accord il a eu
fallu une attaque revendiquée par les
talibans qui avait coûté la vie un
soldat américain est du reste un soldat
roumain également pour le remettre en
cause donc les américains n'ont pas
attendu cet accord pour essayer
d'abonder dans le sens de la promesse
présidentielle que le président donald
trump avait faite à l'occasion de son
élection de sa précédente élection et
qu'il a reformulée à l'occasion du
prochain scrutin en novembre 2020
les américains partent mais partent avec
un calendrier qui est très très étalée
on parle de 14 mois
ils partent de manière séquencée ou 2100
sur les quatorze mille qui sont
actuellement présents au sein d'une
opération otanienne la vraie question
c'est que vont faire les partenaires
donc les autres nations les 28 autres
nations qui appartiennent à l'opération
otanienne qui a donc succédé à
l'opération qui avait évidemment pour
but de chasser les talibans alors que
l'objectif même et le président
américain a été assez limpide pour une
fois c'est de réintroduire les talibans
dans le jeu politique il a même été
assez cynique en disant qu'il est
possible que vu l'état de déconfiture si
on autoriser l'expression des deux camps
que les talibans finalement ne soit la
solution la plus stable dans le contexte
où nous sommes ce soir
est ce que finalement cette stratégie
s'est avérée payante négocier avec les
talibans ça dépend de quel point de vue
on parle du point de vue afghans n'ont
d'ailleurs les afghans ne se
reconnaissent pas dans ce processus
il avale quand même beaucoup de couleurs
près de dix huit années 19 ans années
qui ont coûté la vie à cent mille
afghans avec un coup absolument
considérable on parle de 4000 milliards
de dollars qui ont été dépensés pour le
conflit
avec évidemment des victimes au tant
civils que militaires
les américains imposent ou mettre une
pression assez considérable sur le
président un des deux présidents
autoproclamés a proclamé pardon investi
ashraf ghani qui dans son discours a
laissé entendre que ce qui ne voulait
pas accepter c'est à dire la libération
des cinq mille prisonniers talibans
pourraient éventuellement faire le jeu
d'un compromis
donc l'état les afghans n'ont pas eu
leur mot à dire à la fois dans les
termes de cet accord de paix qui précise
qu' précisément s'appuie sur quatre
points un cessez le feu
un dialogue entre afghans la libération
d'un certain nombre de prisonniers
talibans contre la libération de 1000
forces de sécurité afghanes qui sont
entre les mains des talibans et puis la
promesse mais là aussi avec beaucoup de
guillemets que le mouvement taliban ne
soit plus en lien avec les organisations
terroriste al-qaïda nommément mais l'on
sait que dans tout accord de paix il ya
des absents il y a quelques jours
vendredi précisément 32 personnes sont
mortes à l'issue d'une d'un attentat qui
n'a pas été revendiqué par les talibans
mais par l'état islamique en afghanistan
qui ne se reconnaît dans absolument
aucun des termes de cet accord
justement cet attentat aurait indiqué
aujourd'hui un par lui lors des
cérémonies d'investiture concurrentes
ça dit quoi finalement qu' on est
totalement impuissant à faire la paix
dans ce pays
ça dit que l'accord de paix n'en est pas
un que l'accord de paix est avant tout
un accord entre les américains et les
talibans précisément entre les
américains et l'émirat islamique
d'afghanistan
d'ailleurs dans l'accord en question il
est précisé que les américains ne le
reconnaissent pas cette organisation
mais la manière dont les talibans le
sens revendique montre à quel point les
américains ont d'une certaine façon un
peu capituler de ce point de vue ça dit
surtout que le gouvernement d'achat
frannie est sous la coupe américaine
avec 80 % du budget de l'état qui dépend
de l'aide extérieure
il peut difficilement en être autrement
cela dit également qu'il ya une césure
qui est en train de se créer entre les
jeux politiciens à kaboul qui ressemble
beaucoup à la période qui avait précédé
l'arrivée des talibans 96 la guerre
civile
entre 1992 et 1996 on est dans une
configuration où à quelques centaines de
mètres deux membres qui jusqu'à présent
avaient exercé un magistère régalien
pour l'exercice donc de la souveraineté
afghane
ce sont la guerre politiquement avec
peut-être un peu plus de préoccupations
à voir dans les jours qui viennent avec
d'ores et déjà adoul abdullah qui a
envoyé son vice-président dans le palais
présidentiel pour exercer sa
vice-présidence et un certain nombre de
districts et un certain nombre de
gouverneurs qu'ils sont placés par les
uns et les autres avec cette grande
interrogation que ferait l'armée s'ils
recevaient l'ordre de déloger un camp ou
l'autre
merci beaucoup emmanuel dupuis pour
votre analyse complète merci à vous